[Musique]
j'aime la science vous le savez je suis
persuadé qu'il est un sérieux manque de
culture scientifique dans le grand
public
je suis persuadé qu'il est un sérieux
manque de confiance en les théories
scientifiques
je suis persuadé qu' un sérieux manque
de compréhension du processus
scientifique et le fait que des
scientifiques et des sympathisants des
sciences soient prêts à marcher pour les
sciences est quelque chose qui m'a
grandement réjouit j'étais du coup très
excité à l'idée de participer à la
marche des sciences à genève
le flyer disaient les faits sont des
faits la science indépendante des
intérêts partisans et son biais
bénéficie à l'humanité
le flyer entend par là que des faits
scientifiquement établis ne peuvent pas
être rejetés à moins de preuves
exceptionnel le flyer entend par là que
dans la quasi totalité des cas la
recherche scientifique n'est pas motivée
par une idéologie politique
le flyer entend par là que la science
cherche à nous libérer des préjugés et
prend garde à éviter les biais cognitifs
dont nos cerveaux sont quotidiennement
victimes
le flyer entend par là que la science a
globalement permis un progrès
remarquable est indéniable de la qualité
de vie de la quasi totalité d'entre nous
et je suis parfaitement d'accord avec
ces affirmations clarifier mais je
trouve les affirmations du flyer un
petit peu problématique dire que les
fesses en effet est discutable
les faits sont toujours susceptibles
d'être remis en question après tout ils
sont toujours rapportés et tous rapports
des faits est inéluctable biaisé par
exemple par le shérif pikine de même la
science n'est jamais sans billet pasteur
a défendu la pio génèse cauchy a cru
avoir prouvé que toutes les fonctions
continue son dérive à bhl et einstein a
fondé sa cosmologie sur l'hypothèse
injustifié que l'univers était statique
et éternelle
ici les progrès technologiques
grandement améliorer la production
agricole la santé des citoyens et leur
niveau de vie plus généralement on peut
débattre le fait que toutes les
découvertes scientifiques sont
inévitablement bénéfique en particulier
les ordinateurs quantiques pour à [ __ ]
en l'air tout le système financier
mais bon je pinaille là sur des détails
je le sais pour bien communiquer il faut
simplifier et la simplification
drastique de ces trois points ne m'a pas
contrarier ce qui m'a posé problème
c'est la prétention selon laquelle la
marche n'avait pas d'intérêts partisans
alors je préfère vous prévenir le reste
de cette vidéo va paraître extrêmement
critique
s'il ya des organisateurs ou des
participants de ces événements qui
m'écoutent
sachez que je vous admire et que je vous
remercie du fond du coeur je trouve ça
même complètement fou d'avoir réussi à
fédérer autant de sympathisants des
sciences mon but n'est pas de vous
stigmatisez mon but c'est de fournir une
critique constructive dans l'espoir de
clarifier le message envoyé par ce type
d'événement est d'améliorer la manière
dont on défend les sciences et je
m'excuse d'avancé si ça offense ceux qui
ont cherché à bien faire mais pourraient
se sentir visés par cette vidéo
allons-y
force est de constater que prétendre que
la marche des sciences n'a aucun intérêt
partisan est une pure hypocrisie en fait
aux états unis
la marche pour les sciences était un
mouvement fondamentalement anti trump
est antirépublicain de façon plus
générale
d'ailleurs les manifestants outre
atlantique ne s'en sont pas cachés et
les manifestants à genève où ceux qui
ont pris la parole à genève non plus il
y avait une claire revendications pour
plus d'investissements dans les sciences
quitte à ce que ce soit aux dépens
d'autres investissements potentiels
il y avait une claire revendications
pour une plus grande autorité des
résultats et des experts scientifiques
quitte à ce que ce soit aux dépens de la
vie du grand public il y avait une
claire revendications pour plus de
mesures contre le réchauffement
climatique
quitte à ce que ce soit aux dépens de la
croissance économique il y avait une
claire revendications pour une
législation rendant la vaccination
obligatoire quitte à ce que ce soit aux
dépens des libertés individuelles
il y avait une claire revendications
pour une facilitation de l'immigration
au moins pour les personnes les plus
éduquées quitte à ce que ce soit aux
dépens des citoyens de l'année
et je passe sous silence des
revendications - scientifique sur
l'homosexualité ou le racisme
je ne suis pas contre ces revendications
en fait j'ai même d'un ancêtre plutôt
d'accord avec toutes ces revendications
mais ce que je trouve inacceptables au
point que je préfère aujourd'hui me
dissocier avec ce mouvement c'est le
fait que ces revendications se soient
retrouvées mélangées avec des faits
scientifiques
or aucune de ces revendications les
scientifiques ces revendications sont
toutes des jugements moraux sur ce qui
devrait être ou sur ce qui devrait être
fait cependant la science peut penser
uniquement d'écrire et prédire ce qui
est ou ce qui a de bonnes chances d'être
qui comme le philosophe david comme l'a
très bien expliqué il ya plus de deux
siècles
vous ne pouvez pas déduire un devrait
être à partir d'un est la pensée
prédictive ne peut pas suffire à
impliquer une pensée prescriptive en
particulier la science ne devrait jamais
dicté ce qui devrait être et doit
absolument se restreindre à décrire ce
qui est ou ce qui sera et c'est
d'ailleurs précisément parce que la
science a restreint son champ
d'application lité qu'elle peut
prétendre prédominer sur nos opinions
alors attention je ne suis pas en train
de dire que la science n'a aucun rôle à
jouer en politique
si vous voulez meilleure santé publique
il vous faut absolument comprendre ce
qui cause les maladies et quels sont les
remèdes les plus à même de guerrière
voire d'éradiquer ces maladies si vous
voulez une certaine redistribution des
richesses
il nous faut absolument avoir des
données fiables sur la distribution des
richesses actuelle dans votre pays
si vous voulez diminuer le prix d'un
bien il vous faut absolument comprendre
le marché économique de ce bien et les
conséquences qu'aurait une augmentation
ou une diminution de la régulation
la science doit servir à la prise de
décision cependant faites gaffe à la
manière dont les phrases que je viens
d'énoncer sont construites pour qu'une
revendication politique émerge
il faut absolument avoir combiné la
science avec un objectif subjectifs et
non scientifique la science seule n'a et
n'aura jamais son mot à dire sur ce qui
devrait être en fait un scientifique
peut très bien préférer plus d'être
sociale et moins d'impôts aux dépens de
l'investissement des sciences même s'il
connaît et comprend l'utilité des
sciences
un scientifique pourrait très bien
préféré plus de démocratie
par exemple en donnant plus souvent la
parole aux citoyens aux dépens du temps
de parole accordé aux scientifiques un
scientifique pour être très bien préféré
plus de croissance économique
quitte à dépenser moins de temps et
d'énergie à lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique
un scientifique pourrait très bien
préféré plus de liberté individuelle
plutôt que de forcer chacun de ses
concitoyens à subir la vaccination
un scientifique pourrait très bien
préféré plus de contrôle de
l'immigration dans son pays aux dépens
du recrutement des cerveaux par les
universités certes la plupart des
scientifiques n'ont pas de telles
revendications politiques
cependant aucune de ces revendications
n'est incompatible avec la science
encore une fois les revendications
politiques concerne ce qui devrait être
pas ce qui est jeu paraît que la plupart
des citoyens ont une compréhension
partielle et intuitive de tout cela il
pense sans doute que les revendications
politiques ne peuvent pas être objective
il pense sans doute que les
revendications politiques sont sujettes
à être débattue il pense sans doute que
les revendications politiques sont comme
les goûts et les couleurs
dès lors la politisation de la marche
les sciences risque fortement de
conduire à une décrédibilisation des
faits scientifiques
après tout quand un scientifique affirme
que lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique est plus important que la
croissance économique est il vraiment en
train de mentionner un fait scientifique
quant à scientifiques demandent plus
d'investissements dans les sciences sa
position n'était pas subjective est
sujette à la remise en cause
et si la science commence à parler de ce
qui devrait être
n'est-elle pas en train de devenir
juste une question de goûts et de
couleurs
si je n'étais
pas aussi sensibilisés à la distinction
entre les sciences prédictive et les
opinions prescriptive l' amalgame
maladroit des faits scientifiques et des
revendications politiques à la marche
des sciences de genève
m'aurait conduit à conclure que la
science ou du moins le message envoyé
par ce qui semble parler au nom de la
science n'est peut être finalement
qu'une question d'opinion comme les
autres je me serais donc autorisé à
rejeter les faits scientifiques qui me
déplaisent c'est cette observation qui
m'attend contrarier pendant la marche
des sciences amis scientifique et
sympathisants des sciences il nous faut
absolument être beaucoup plus clair dans
la distinction entre ce qui relève des
préférences des goûts et des
revendications politiques et ce qui
relève des faits et des sciences le
réchauffement climatique est un fait
scientifique
l'appel à lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique n'en est pas un je crains que
ne pas faire clairement cette
distinction a de bonnes chances de
nourrir et augmenter le scepticisme
envers les sciences
alors je ne suis pas en train de dire
que la marche des sciences ne doit pas
avoir un but politique
en fait il me semble que la communauté
scientifique partagent de nombreuses
valeurs le progrès la curiosité
l'ouverture la tolérance l'humilité ou
encore la rigueur qui a à mon avis est
seulement à mon avis pas au nom des
sciences devrait aussi être défendus
mais il faut que l'on fasse beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup plus
attention à ne pas mettre dans le même
panier
ces valeurs et les faits scientifiques
les valeurs comme les revendications
politiques sont de l'ordre de l'opinion
or le message qui me semble le plus
important à communiquer et que les faits
scientifiques bien établie ne sont pas
une histoire d'opinion bout du compte
j'ai l'impression qu'on a choisi une
bataille des plus délicates
on a typiquement envie de défendre à la
fois la fiabilité des sciences et
l'investissement dans les sciences
cependant le second n'étant pas une
revendication scientifique il serait
maladroit de la défendre au nom des
sciences